[Music]
[Applause]
as well
we make way for uh cameron as uh
loyal to chicago beats number one
illinois on sunday
next up is oregon state my ramblers
cameron joining us now on the program
cameron congratulations
how you feeling thank you thank you
thanks for having me on i like to
i like the little knickknacks we got
here in the front thank you
look at him thank you uh how long we've
been working on the mustache
uh i don't know it's been like uh it's
been about
eight months been a quarantine thing
kind of started in quarantine and just
kind of let let it run
you know and now people are are falling
in love with it yeah
what's not to fall in love with does the
coach uh give you grief about it
uh no no not really i mean uh back in my
freshman year i was rocking the mutton
chops
during the final four run so now
i switched it up and went with the
mustache so i don't know it's just
something fun to do
and just kind of adds to the to the
lore i guess to the aura that you that
you are
um if somebody hasn't seen your team
play how would you describe your style
uh together chemistry you know we like
to play together and play the right way
defense tough physical we talk a ton
about physical without fouling
i think i think we do a really good job
of you know
staying on top of teams strengths and
and trying to limit their strengths and
i think we did a great job against that
the illini this weekend just trying to
take away one or two you're not gonna be
able to take away
their whole attack i mean they're too
good so we tried to limit their use of
ball screens
um you know trapped io a lot in the ball
screen and um
you know just tried to work not to let
uh
big kofi try to catch the ball in the
middle there you know sometimes it
breaks down but uh
you know we just we just gave our all do
you feel like underdogs
you know that's that's the funny thing
um you know maybe in 2018 we kind of you
know snuck up on some people
and people were like oh we don't you
know
kind of underestimated us and stuff but
now no it's no secret you know no one's
no one's underestimating us
and uh you know when you play the
ramblers you're gonna you know you're in
for
for a good game and uh you know we we uh
i don't really think we're underdogs
anymore you know people are starting to
take notice of us and
especially you know all those feelings
that people had
in 2018 now they're they're kind of
coming back to life and uh i i'm just
happy
that we prove that you know that that
year wasn't a fluke um you know you hear
about so many teams like that coming out
and you know you have a final four run
then you kind of just
fade off and into the college basketball
scene but we've been able to
to sustain it how many scholarship
offers did you have
uh i had about uh like 35 scholarship
offers
uh coming out of high school not nothing
nothing from the power five though so
definitely definitely kind of put a chip
on my shoulder for sure
and uh definitely you know that's the
same with all these guys that you know
came to loyal we we all kind of have
that chip on our shoulder
um you know personally i felt that i
could have played at the highest level
and um you know but but i also wanted to
go somewhere where i was a fit you know
so i i could have
i could have probably i committed to
loyola really early my career
in my high school career before my
senior year i could have probably waited
and played my senior year out and i
probably would have got a lot of offers
just
just you know from big schools not
getting the guys that they wanted but
i wanted to go somewhere where you know
they wanted me and and i could make an
impact and um
you know it worked out how would you
describe your style itself
uh like my play yeah my playstyle yeah
i mean i just think uh uh you know high
iq i
understand the game you know i'm not
gonna beat anyone with
with blazing speed or uh you know i'm
not gonna jump over anybody but um you
know there's so many different ways to
play the game of basketball
um it's not all about athleticism and
speed and
quickness it's all you know
understanding how other teams are
playing you understanding their
coverages understanding
what this guy doesn't like and what he
does like um you know being able to play
i feel like you know i i hate to kind of
to my own horn here but i feel like i
you know
i'm making other guys better on the
floor you know i'm attracting a lot of
attention um setting dudes up um you
know
it's definitely positionless in my book
i mean you know i'm i'm
listed as a center but you know i for me
basketball you got to be able to dribble
pass and shoot so um you know i i've
always kind of been that way
ever since i was a kid i was always kind
of like dribbling and passing and stuff
so
you kind of remind me of uh the joker
joking yeah
yeah that's what a lot of people are
saying right now um obviously
he can he can he's that that's funny
that you say that because a lot of
people are always
you're like the college joker and stuff
man he's incredible
um you know i watch him i watch him a
lot um
you know and and he is incredible he the
way he shoots and his touch is
unbelievable i mean
um just the way he passes he's always
thinking one or two steps ahead and
that's something i kind of
pride myself on um as far as you know
being able to see the play maybe two
three steps ahead than everyone else but
um yeah he's incredible he's having an
mvp season right now yeah it's not a bad
comparison there cameron
uh cameron crutwig the uh loyola chicago
center
uh i was told you didn't bring your
harmonica which i don't believe for a
second because you're trying to focus on
basketball
yeah you have a harmonica don't you i do
okay
okay well i was it's in my room i'm so
the wi-fi here isn't the best so i had
to come down to the
to to another room with like a wired
connection so
i left a harmonica back in my oh my gosh
like this stuff before i come on here
fritzy i
said to tell cameron to bring the damn
harmonies
we threw it on him at the last minute
okay now you do love the same music as
my booker fritzy holland oates yeah
billy joel yeah billy joe elton john
little rolling stones leonard skynyrd
okay
so your go-to karaoke song is oh
that's a tough one um i think
uh we we were doing so we went to
karaoke place um
and me and my buddy on the team we sang
uh hello by adele
that was got the people going a little
bit me and my buddy uh will
uh who's a walk on here can you give me
just a little can you give me just a
little
for rambler nation okay how about this
you love you love uh hall of notes
fritzy
is a huge holly notes fan what's your
favorite holland oats song
my favorite's private eyes but i
understand man
yeah that's a good choice that is a good
choice okay that's
my dad's favorite all right cameron
fritzy's gonna start
and i'll do the collapse no you've got
to give me just a little
just a little taste for rambler nation
here come on all right
you can do it i mean you're not afraid
of anything come on no i'm not
okay all right fritzy are you ready i am
okay all right here we go
i see you when you see me
watch you blow in the lines when you're
making a scene oh
you've got to know what my head
overlooks
the senses will show to my heart when
it's watching for lies
you can't escape my private
that's good man that is good stuff all
right all right
made my day thank you yes all right give
me the other thing i hear you do a will
ferrell impersonation and will ferrell
is watching the program right now oh man
if he's watching right now i love will
ferrell okay semi-pro is like the
greatest movie of all time well
i understand that but will ferrell's in
our bracket challenge i don't know if he
picked you guys but will watches every
morning
he didn't pick us i don't know that i
don't know could you guys check and see
what up yeah can you pull up will
ferrell's bracket there and let me know
all right so what's your welfare on
impersonation from what movie
ah semi-pro okay for sure okay
um there's so many good lines i i like
i like the part where uh dukes
dukes has got the big check and he's
like
jackie it's written in glitter man he's
like i don't know what to tell you dukes
you might want to find a bank with a big
check department
can i just get like a normal sized jack
jackie
that's that's the funny part or when
he's uh when he's uh
what do you do dukes uh nothing
right now laying low i like it
where are you from dukes flint michigan
homegrown dukes is homegrown
uh did we find out did farrell pick
loyola i don't want to be the bearer of
bad news he did not
come on well you know what
he's regretting that he's got to be
regretting that now
yeah you guys did some damage to
brackets like do you feel guilty at all
that you hurt some people's brackets
here cameron
no i don't feel bad at all i feel pretty
good
um no i think uh you know when we came
into this
we wanted to win games uh you know i i
think that every game that we've
we've played so far we've played with
that chip that edge on our shoulder
and when we've come out we've we've done
it um
you know we all wanted that one
yesterday um you know as soon as we saw
that
so we were at um we're at the indy 500
speedway for first election sunday
and we we saw the first two brackets and
we had a feeling we're going to be an
eight or nine and then we saw illinois
as the one
and we all just kind of looked and we
like before we had even came we're like
ah here it comes here it comes and then
uh you know sure as it is hc was loyal
in chicago and uh
you know we not that we were circling
that game you know we always got to
worry about that first one
um you know but um when it when it came
and we beat georgia tech and
and it was time for for illinois you
know we we really wanted that game and
you know it's just a great game all
right can we make a bet can we can we
make a date
i don't know if i'm allowed to bet oh no
ncaa rules you're right
you're right yep yep you're the grown-up
in the room
um come on get me in trouble when you
beat
oregon state all right
when you beat them now you want me to
say if
well we gotta we respect everyone okay
okay if you beat oregon state
next monday a week from today
harmonica we're gonna have a game on
monday
we're gonna be in the elite eight then
oh you have a game on monday as well
yeah oh damn
sorry to okay how about this because i
could skip the game
okay i could skip it okay
no okay if oh you are kidding okay yeah
if um
so this is gonna be i was trying to get
will ferrell on
oh man that i mean we could do that
tomorrow
[Laughter]
okay you just named the time and place
if if i get will ferrell on tomorrow
yes harmonica
i will bring the harmonic out okay let
me see what i can do fritzing
just see what you can do just just see
but i want you to focus on basketball
today okay
well today was kind of like an off day
for us um just i mean we played two
three two games in three days so you got
homework to do cameron
oh you got some homework about that
later
uh fritzy reach out to will ferrell and
see if will would like to come on
and and we'll do our best cameron all
right hey you take care of your part of
the
this and and we'll take care of our part
of this all right
yeah all right that sounds good to me
ask him why he didn't pick us in the
brackets though
no you'll get to ask him okay i'll ask
him
uh congrats great story again and uh
and hopefully we'll get a chance to talk
to you all right
sounds good that's it thanks for having
me on again and and go ramblers man go
ramblers
all right cameron crutwig the loyola
chicago senior center